well wednesday was a bigger day than
usual because it was the commissioner's
annual pre-super bowl press conference
security was high for some reason they
were taking a closer look at credentials
i'm not sure why they would have done
that but they did and once everybody got
inside and was assembled for the session
the commissioner eventually it took
several questions for him to get there
once he got there he got asked several
questions about it addressing the no
call from the nfc championship game
between the rams and the saints the past
interference that was missed also a
legal hit to a defenseless receiver
missed in real time the commissioner
eventually was asked point blank why did
it take you so long to address the
mistake
we addressed this immediately after the
game
we spoke to the coach the coach
announced
the conversation and that just the fact
that this place should have been called
and we had several conversations with
those
clubs and other officials over the next
several days that's that's our process
that's what we always do with
particularly with judgment calls
and so
it was handled no differently other than
to make sure that we
listen and communicated that to the to
the officials they did a lot of
communicating we did a lot of
communicating for things like rule 17
and others that came up uh as i said to
you over our history uh unfortunately we
have had officiating errors and
other factors
that have
been a lot of focus and news
but the game of football is played on
the field
and
they're played by humans they're coached
by humans and they're officiated by
humans and that's what our game is
and so
we think that uh we're proud obviously
of having the patriots and the rams here
we understand the disappointment of the
saints fans the organization and the
players and we understand that
that talking point finally came out
coached by humans played by humans
officiated by humans that's not good
enough they need to find ways to improve
the officiating but a couple of things
from that he mentioned rule 17 which is
the device that gives him the authority
to go back and change an outcome replay
a game go to a specific point in the
game and the fact that came up as part
of the communications with the saints
yeah that tells me there were some
heated communications right the saints
are saying hey you should do something
about this under rule 17. that that
means it got very serious and the idea
that they didn't come out and make a
public statement because sean payton
came out and publicly acknowledged that
he got a phone call well there have been
15 to 30 instances over the last 15
years with the nfl has publicly
acknowledged a mistake i i still think
they should have said something that
night so so they just let us know that
yes we made a mistake and we're going to
try to find a way to not make this
mistake in the future i think you put it
perfectly a couple weeks ago when you
said the nfl their their strategy is
always to do nothing sit watch public
reaction then deny and say that you know
this isn't what happened and that's
exactly how it went down all they had to
do was come out say we screwed up we
made a huge error we're very very sorry
it's it's it what roger goodell said
there is not wrong it's a human game
with human officials and human mistakes
and i think we all recognize it but not
being able to say that right after the
moment and having to wait a week and a
half that is a fault and that makes the
league look stupid yeah i i i can't
disagree with uh some of that for sure i
mean yes they addressed it they
addressed it with the people that were
affected you know but again i think the
thing that bothers me is
kind of the hypocrisy of the nfl once
again they're going to tell players and
coaches to be good leaders and and do
all those type of things well hey great
leadership would have got up in front of
a podium
shortly after that game whether it was
the next day or the day after and you
just have to take this situation head-on
and deal with it and make a statement
like you're both saying and just say hey
we really messed up here there's no
doubt about that we're sorry and i think
we wouldn't be talking about it as much
right now and he wouldn't have addressed
it as much as he did yesterday if they
just kind of got in front of it a little
bit i just thought of something while we
were discussing it which shows that i do
absolutely no prep for the show because
i would have thought of this if i had
spent time
when he mentions rule 17 within the
confines of the communications they had
with the saints it makes me wonder
whether or not they resisted admitting
right after the game that the mistake
was made because that ends up being the
first domino that potentially could
become this chain of hey the rams are
still in town they haven't gotten on the
plane yet let's go back get them back
out let's get everybody back there now
you can't do it tuesday you can't do it
wednesday you can't do it next sunday
everybody's still here everybody's still
got a sweat going let's go back out and
play the one final one minute 49 seconds
of the game do you think he was
referring to that conversation there or
just the fact that rule 17 came up no
what i mean is
if they had maybe rule 17 came up right
out of the gates maybe sean payton in
the first conversation said hey there's
authority in the rule book i mean i
assume these coaches know the rules yeah
right hey there's authority to go back
and fix this and and so if they don't
acknowledge it as it was a mistake you
never liked the fuse you never have to
hit right rule 17 the interesting thing
going forward would be how this all
played out now the rule 17 is well known
everyone knows this rule everyone knows
that cadell has this authority will he
be sitting there in a championship game
next year saying there could be a
scenario where i have to enact this and
basically go back and play replay a game
with a couple minutes left i don't think
it ever will yeah right but it does add
a little element there that's
interesting to watch well he was asked
point blank yesterday whether he has the
power to use it and he claims that he
doesn't in this situation then why is it
in there well and there's there's a
specific provision in there that makes
it clear it's not a device for teams to
make protests and say we because
otherwise every week somebody said right
we invoke rule 17 right hey we don't
like that outcome rules
and keep them in town so he's got to go
investigate rule 17 and and decide
whether or not it applies he doesn't
want anyone to force him to do it he
wants to have the power to do it and he
kind of boxed himself in because he
suggested he doesn't have the power to
replay the ending of a game based upon a
bad call i think he still does and i
don't think that that takes it off the
table i just don't know why you have
that rule in place if you're i mean when
would you ever use it that's what i've
been trying to get the nfl to tell me
give me an
idea of what it would take this rule is
there it's there for a reason when would
you ever use it yeah i i don't i can't
even imagine when you would use it what
would be the instance to
i mean are you smart enough to come up
with no i'm not i'm not but somebody who
is told me that it would be an example
like let's say you were on the sideline
remember when you're on the sideline
recently and a guy ran into your mind i
do remember that thank you very much for
bringing that up let's say that you that
you had careened off of that official
and you had ended up like taking out
tyree kill if he's getting ready to
catch the game-winning touchdown pass
and the officials didn't notice it and
didn't do anything about it and just let
it all stand that's the kind of thing
where the commissioner could say wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute good
example half of wild dogs runs on the
scale right right rule seven rule 17.
actually begins to feast on the
quarterback we need to do this though
you need to have a sit down with goodell
and just have a list of hypotheticals
and say rule 17 or not all right just go
right i go back to something you said
though shortly after this and i think it
was spot on again it really stinks that
this happened like we don't like this
but
it's this is super bowl 53 we've never
seen it happen and you know i mean again
i don't think we have to reinvent the
rule book and every nfl bylaw just
because i think this is a
once-in-a-generation type of decision i
disagree but this doesn't happen that
often like you're basically what you're
saying is you need to change the entire
way we play football and the replay
system no i think that we need to have
and and the thing i keep coming back to
and mike pereira agrees with me so i'm
going to embrace if he disagreed with me
i'd say he's stupid but he he agrees
with me
you you add an eighth official who is
there to watch
the tv screens to watch the monitors to
provide the perspective that the seven
officials on the field don't have
because there's a gap between what those
folks have number one they're trying to
stay alive because they're out there
middle-aged and older potentially
getting trampled they can't see what's
happening right you put an official in
the booth who sees everything and can
say hey ad hocule or clete blakeman or
whoever throw the flag pick up the flag
we missed that we missed it okay so all
right so let's go from that how many
times a game do you think that's going
to happen how many times a game we're
going to stop the game yeah you don't
stop the game okay you just talk just
like you know you think you're gonna
happen that quickly because i don't
think it can happen but i also well i
also know that on sundays when we sat
together and watched games you would get
annoyed because you felt like they were
waiting for the video boards right time
for calls they were waiting for new york
to get in their ear to set up i don't
want to go we don't like we don't like
this call or anything like that now add
on that here's the other part of this
that i don't think works okay
you have seven guys seven refs who want
to be trusted they all i'm not gonna say
they have egos but everyone wants to
think that they're doing the best job
they can do now you have an eighth guy
watching over them telling them every
time they screw up you know buzzing them
every time they miss a little thing
right and those guys on the field are
saying well guess what you're not on the
field you're not seeing this you know
live time live time happening right in
front of your face now you have the
second guessing fact i think that's
second guessing it's it's a very simple
what you've done is given a simple
solution and it's not that simple
it's a lot more complicated than what
you've seen if you if you use in that
spot
people who no longer have the physical
ability to run around on the field let's
say you know 65 70 years old can't do it
anymore but still have that wealth of
knowledge have the authority right and
talk to the referee and se and and i
think it can be done very efficiently we
see referees huddle we see them huddle
all the time to talk about calls we'll
see that once a game where two officials
come together and they decide whether or
not how many calls are they going to say
yeah like how many times
right and if if you see something that
is dramatically different than what the
ruling is and because here's the thing
but what's the line i'm going to be for
dramatics
at home who played football that's not
your match is it pass interference is it
you know and
the refs are calling the game one way
throughout the entire game then the guy
up in the booth is calling it a
completely different way the refs you
don't know what the refs are saying but
hey guys we're gonna let you get away
we're gonna let you play on the line
right we're gonna let you get away with
a little something we want to let you
play physical what is the guy upstairs
saying oh well that's hold oh well
that's face guard you know what i mean
but the guy upstairs is part of the crew
the referee's still in charge but he's
not but but he is but he never will be
put him in put him in black and white
stripes and maybe you rotate maybe you
have an eight person crew and like they
rotate one person out every game and so
it's you're on the field one week and
you're up there you had a 65 year old
guy upstairs well now he's downstairs
right now i'm changing i'm changing
he's out lawyering you today let me say
one thing he is out lawyering you today
i'm just telling you he is all over you
let me i object strenuously let me say
one thing
the the idea the idea what was i going
to say oh he's got you flustered big
time
you won't let me see no mike
at the end of the day i like i'm all for
making everything better here right i
want the perfect nfl i want the perfect
i don't want to see teams lose out on a
super bowl because of a missed call but
i think it's a lot more complicated than
people are making it out to be and i
think saying well just throw some guy up
in the booth or just throw it kick it to
new york
you are going to sit there on sunday and
be upset when there are 10 reviews and
you're sitting there and it's replay and
replay and commercial and commercial
four-hour games let me just say one
thing yeah something chris was alluding
to earlier and he didn't give me a
chance to explain what happens when we
watch the games at nbc and you see all
of them being played at once you can
tell
when
the referee is hearing from al river on
at 345 park avenue and perhaps being
told to do something that our river on
doesn't have the authority technically
right to tell him to do so that already
happens you already have some obvious
errors being corrected from time to time
off the books by riveron and think of it
this way if al riveron had simply said
to bill vinovich
in that moment drop a flag there was
obvious passages we would be having
no we wouldn't if because they're not
going to admit it to us but we would see
a flag drop there's 95 cameras and we'd
go damn they dropped the flight 15
seconds after the play it happens well
that would then we'd be talking about do
you deserve to be here though we would
not be talking about why because the
right the referendum
wasn't really calling it yeah and
where's the late flag for the face
massage
that's right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports